Hello everyone, this
is Isaac Kurtzer,
the Department
of Biomedical
Science at the Old
Westbury campus.
This lecture concerns
supraspinal motor
systems, cerebral
cortex, and brainstem.
It's the first of
three. The next will
be basal ganglia
and cerebellum, and
taken together,
they'll provide a good
introduction to a
complex issue, which I
know is close at
heart, which is how is
it that you are able
to move your body?
The session objectives
for this lecture
include understanding
the origin
and destination of
descending tracts
from the cerebral
cortex and brainstem,
for which there
are quite a few.
I will also contrast
the different and
complementary
organizations of these
systems and their
overall function.
And finally, we
address how damaging
the different
systems will lead to
different patterns
of motor dysfunction.
Let's go.
A key distinction we
must make is between
lower motor neurons and
upper motor neurons.
Lower motor neurons
are those that will
innervate skeletal muscle.
That means there'll
be a neuromuscular
junction, and they will
release acetylcholine
onto a target muscle.
The cell bodies for
these loader motor
neurons are found
within the CNS.
They will have an
axon that will exit
the CNS and then
ultimately terminate
at the neuromuscular
junction.
When that axon
is within the
CNS, it is
called a tract.
When the axon is
outside the CNS, i.e.
when it's in the PNS,
it's called a nerve.
and external nerves
always project
ipsilaterally. Internal
tracks for the low motor
neurons almost always
are ipsilateral.
They do decussate,
but it's quite rare.
Now turning to upper
motor neurons, these
provide input to
lower motor neurons.
They have cell bodies
in the cerebral
cortex and the brainstem.
So they will be
projecting to those
lower motor neurons
in the brainstem and
the spinal cord, not
directly to muscle.
They will not have
a nerve. They will
only have tracts. And
these tracts, they
could decussate or
they couldn't, and
they could project
bilaterally. There's
a variety of patterns.
Those neurons whose
cell body are within the
cerebral cortex and
descend to lower motor
neurons within the spinal
cord and brainstem,
those are collectively
called the pyramidal
system and that will
include the cortical
spinal tract which is
going to be traveling
to the spinal cord and
includes the cortical
bulbar tract which will
be traveling to the
brain stem and so keep
this naming convention
in mind cortical
spinal where it begins
where it ends cortical
bulbar starting in the
cortex ending in the
bulb the bulb of what
that's the brain stem
the bulb of the flower
of which we have the
cerebral cortex being
the elaboration and
then we have the stem
being for the brain
stem now this naming
convention the pyramidal
system is a little
bit funny because it's
going to be referring
to the pyramids which
are only for the
cortical spinal tract
and not the cortical
bulbar system so it's
like all hands on deck
they're only referring
to a part of the
person the hands to
say they're on deck
suffice to say this
is a language that is
standard the pyramidal
system includes those
neurons that will be
traveling through the
medullary period
pyramids as well as those
that will be ending
within the brain stem
so where are the cell
bodies of the pyramidal
system well they're
going to be in the
region that is anterior
to the central sulcus
that is they're within
the frontal lobe and
more specifically it
will be the precentral
gyrus and then interior
to that the area six
and so we have area
four which is the same
thing as precentral gyrus
which is functionally
called premotor cortex
the region ahead of
that rostral to that
is area six called
premotor cortex and then
supplemental area is
above that we see these
regions on the medial
wall as well this is
the mid sagittal view
there are several major
brain regions that
project to the pyramidal
system and allow it
to express the rich
behavior that we have
the rich number of skills
that all of us have
standing up crossing
our legs pouring a cup
of coffee and so on okay
it's not just pyramidal
system acting alone
it's conjunction
with these other systems
and that will include
the basal ganglia and
the cerebellum and
cortical association areas
in the frontal cortex
and parietal cortex
and the first two basal
ganglia and cerebellum
are together called
the extra pyramidal
system because outside
the pyramidal system
you could call these
upper upper motor neurons
because they're not
going to be projecting
to lower motor neurons
they'll be projecting
to upper motor neurons
which then will
project to lower motor
neurons now this
designation extra pyramidal
has been around for
quite a while and it has
a use once again as
i um there's this
distinction between language
that you find within
the medical community
and language that
you find within the
basic science researcher
this is not to speak
ill of one or the
other but communication
differences between
the two and utility
within each of these
communities so in basic
science the people
will not be referring
to the basal ganglia
as extra pyramidal
but within clinical
context this is this is
common especially when
it comes to symptoms
but motor symptoms
of dysfunction and
that are not due to
damage of the pyramidal
system but to these
extra pyramidal systems
and typically people
are referring to
symptoms that relate to
basal ganglia, but
they may also mean the
cerebellum. And
there is a particular
relationship, as we'll
see in succeeding
lectures, between the
basal ganglia and the
cerebellum to the
pyramidal system, and that
is the cerebral
cortex is yoked to
ipsilateral basal and
contralateral cerebellum.
Now there is regional
specialization between
the primary motor
cortex, premotor cortex,
and supplemental motor
area. The primary
motor cortex is going
to be providing the
greatest input to the
descending tracts that
will be destined to
the corticospinal
tract and the corticobulbar
tract. When we're
looking at the
corticospinal tract, we can
say how many synapses
are found from primary
motor cortex for the
cervical level. And
we can go from C2 to
T2 in a monkey and
count out those synaptic
connections and we
can see that it grows
as reflecting the
cervical enlargements
and the number that are
shown here is much
larger than the number
that are shown here for
the very same specimen
which was a monkey
but certainly would
be the case in your if
you're human as well
there's important
functional differences
amongst the various
regions that comprise the
pyramidal system and
is as follows that
primary motor cortex is
going to have the closest
relationship to
muscle activity at the
most direct relationship
to an action whereas
premotor cortex and
SMA will have uh less
direct relationships more
abstract relationship
for a given action
so it would be let's
say example the
planning of the action
well that's more abstract
because you're not
actually acting at
a given moment it's
that the plan for the
action or um say sma
where you have the
initiation of the action
still more abstract
or sequences of
actions which by
necessity have to be
compressed and organized
in a more complex way
and so this complexity
and abstraction
is going to flow from
caudal to rostral
regions basically as
you're moving closer and
closer to the frontal
pole of frontal lobe.
On the right you can
see an example of this
where primary motor
cortical neurons that
are sensitive to
wrist flexion will be
engaged during the go cue
to say flex your wrist
dear monkey and so
there's a burst of
activity whereas neurons
that are in primary
pre-motor cortex of
the same animal will be
active in this delay
period when the animal
is cued to it will
soon need to flex the
wrist so it is
directionally specific for
flexion versus extension
of what is planned
ahead so that's
obviously a difference in
abstraction here we
have a depiction of the
sensory homunculus and
motor homunculus both
are from the left
hemisphere of the brain.
The motor homunculus
is shown on the right
but actually originates
from the left because
it's being flipped
around being flipped
around this dotted line
vertical dotted line of
the central sulcus
and that is separating
the pre-central sulcus
from the post-central
sulcus. In both cases,
you see a similar layout
of the body surface.
We have the face
being most lateral and
the leg being most medial
on the post-central
and pre-central gyri.
Both cases, we have a
great deal of cortical
territory devoted to
the face and devoted
to the hand relative
to their actual sizes
that's why this is a
very impactful image
to see how large the
hand is how large the
face is as represented
within the human
brain as opposed to
the physical space that
we see in the periphery
now there's not as
much difference if
you were to track the
number of afferent
fibers that are coming
from it. There's a
huge number of afferent
fibers and a huge number
of motor efferents.
Still, you have this
cortical magnification,
a continuing multiplying
of information that
allows you to have
the great sensory and
motor acuity for these
functions. the cortical
spinal track will arise
from neurons whose
cell bodies are within
m1 pm and sma that's
the regions that are
immediately interior of
the central sulcus on
the dorsal two-thirds
and medial wall those
axons will collect
and then descend through
the superhighway of
the internal capsule
continue on through the
midbrain continue on
through the pons and
then the medulla
decussating at its lowermost
limit and continuing
to the uh to the spinal
cord ventral horn
and so it's in the um
spinal cord this
is called the lateral
corticospinal
tract so this is
one of the fununculi
of the spinal cordans.
About 80 to 90 percent
of axons make this
decussation and 10 percent
continue ipsilaterally
as the ventral
spinal cerebellar tract,
not spinal cerebellar
CST, and they will for
the most part decussate
at the level that
they'll innervate a
given muscle. and so
you will have this
relationship that you
should burn into your mind
that the cerebral
cortex of one side will
control the contralateral
body here's image
showing a frontal
section through the brain
and we'll be able to
envision the fibers
descending from the
cerebral cortex down through
a portion of the
brain stem so remember
the cell bodies will
be part of this gray
matter that is this that
is the cerebral cortex
this gray matter and
then the axons will
collect together and
descend and they are
forming the internal
capsule the internal
capsule itself includes
fibers they're coming
up from thalamus to
cerebral cortex. It is
a major highway of
information. So it has
both ascending and
descending fibers. Now
returning to the
descending fibers, they're
going to continue through
the cruce cerebri.
So this is a cross
section of the midbrain.
You'll be seeing this in
detail in the upcoming
labs. So it will be
descending through
the crucery. Right
next to that we can see
the substantia *****
for reference. They're
so very dark. And then
those fibers disperse
as they travel through
the ponds because
there's a traffic jam
of information as the
fibers from the pontine
nuclei cross right
to left and left to
right to form that
middle cerebellar
peduncle. And so there's
these descending fibers
have to find their
own individual way
through this traffic
jam and then recoalesce
at the very top of
the medulla to form
the medullary pyramids,
and then at the end,
mostly decussating
at the caudal portion
of the medulla, which
is the medullary
pyramidal decussation.
Now, if you have damage
to anywhere above
that decussation, it
would lead to motor
deficits on the contralateral
side of the body.
why because if I damage
the tracks here well
they're ultimately
destined to the other
side I just snip them
before they made that
decussation but they
would have a terminal
effect contralaterally
so if I damage them
before there's that
decussation you'll see
the effect on the
opposite side whereas if I
damage the lateral
spinal cord which means
for most of the fibers
that had already crossed
on over then the
effect would be seen on
that very same side
there's a variety of
situations that can
lead to damage of the
corticospinal tract it
could be acute like a
****** or spinal cord
injury it could be
something that accrues
over time like multiple
sclerosis maybe something
that you're born
with and as expressed
as you are developing
as a young child like
cerebral palsy in all
these cases you would
have impaired voluntary
movement that include
diminished strength
speed and agility and
what is affected most
are the different
portions of the body so
much less for the
proximal joints and axial
movements why because
that homunculus that
we saw that had such
a large representation
for the hands and the
uh the feet compared
to the um um legs and
trunks and so damaging
this the the pyramidal
uh track these
corticospinal tracts
that have that homunculus
representations mean
you'd specifically damage
the areas that have
the most representation
okay now the positive
clinical symptoms
that one might see would
be things that would
not normally occur that's
why it's a positive
clinical symptoms
as opposed to these
negative ones that are
a diminishment of what
is normal so positive
clinical symptoms would
reflect quote-unquote
release of brainstem
and spinal circuitries
that were previously
either not expressed
or under some well
-managed control they
are incorporated into
healthy behavior and so
this includes increased
stretch reflexes
abnormal synergies a
Babinski sign and I'll
have a slide touching on
those next this slide
is going to be shown
three examples of
dysfunction of the
corticospinal tract
augmented stretch reflexes
abnormal synergies
altered walking so stretch
reflexes you could see
it um either with a
tendon tap that the
leg swings up in this
example the person's
obviously is told don't
don't kick the doctor
i'm just gonna tap your
leg let's see what
happens if it swings up
a little bit okay
that's normal but if it
swings up a lot okay this
is uh altered stretch
reflexes in this case
uh image on the um
left it was because
the physician passively
rotated um their forearm
such that the elbow
extended and uh for
a healthy individual
only with with very
fast uh elbow extension
uh motions imposed do we
see a burst of activity
whereas the individual
that has cst
damage we see a burst
of activity at the very
lowest levels of
imposed motion abnormal
synergies you're probably
less familiar with
this is going to be
couplings between different
joints that aren't
normally expressed and
are clearly dysfunctional
so this person was
instructed just to a
b duct their arm But
what they do instead
is the AB duct plus
elbow flexion, plus
wrist flexion, plus the
fingers all collapsing
together into flexion.
This is obviously
dysfunctional behavior.
This is not going to be
satisfactory to reach
out forward to grab a
cup of soda in front
of you because you can't
open your arms. You
can't reach on out
because your elbow is
flexed. These are very
disruptive behaviors.
And this is not going
to be expressed on
day one of the ******
or spinal cord damage.
Initially, what you'd
have is just plain
weakness and flaccidity.
That's called
spinal shock. But given
some time, this problem
will manifest. best.
Last example is
altered walking. So
we see this individual
that has hemiparesis
on the right side of
the body. Here we see
on the left because
facing us. And so
they're placing all their
weight onto their
unaffected side. And as
they are moving their
right leg forward,
it is being lifted
pretty much at the hip
remember i said that
the proximal joints
are affected less and
so they can't control
the um the muscles
controlling the knee
and the ankle and uh
toes as well and so that
is kind of somewhat
locked into place
and they swing it around
like a log of wood
and you can see at
very end how the toes
are pointed there's
this inversion of the
foot and that's
reflecting spasticity so
these all have classical
signs of corticospinal
damage here we have
a cartoon example
of the normal response
to ****** of the
bottom of the foot
from the heel to the
ball, and that
would be that
the toes curl downwards.
With corticospinal
damage, one could have
the Babinski sign.
You don't want this.
The Babinski sign or
a positive Babinski,
which is a bit
redundant, is this and
is indicative of
damage to the CST. If
the big toe flares
up and the other toes
fan out, you have
yourself a Balinski.
This is normal for
infants under one year
old. I'm not exactly
sure why. I've
never heard a good
reason why it would be,
it would reflect some
functionality of an
infant. Maybe it
reflects just nothing,
you know, really at
all except that a
stage in development
obviously infants under
one aren't walking
around so much so
regardless with spinal
cord well with damaging
at any point that
will interrupt the
cortical spinal tract
be it in a cerebral
cortex or internal
capsule or the lateral
phenunculus which
is going contain the
um cortical spinal
tract axons you could
have this misbehavior
being re-expressed
so it's been there
that entire time it's
just been kept quiet
and you could also
have it in otherwise
healthy individuals
don't ****** out but
they had this um ictal
state they had a seizure
which is basically
going to render a
cerebral cortex having
less effectivity
normal effectiveness at
the peripheral level
so you can see it in
that case as well a
lesion of lower motor
neurons either at the
ventral horn or the
nerve that is going
to be projecting to
the muscle same neurons
right part of it
is going to be the cell
bodies in the ventral
horn and then their
axons which part
of the same cell in
the nerve damaging
either of those will
lead to the same result
flaccidity of the muscle.
You cannot activate
that muscle. You cannot
have acetylcholine
release to it. And
this is going to
have obvious impact
on voluntary strength.
You're going to have
diminished reflexes
because you've removed
one half of the
reflex arc. You have
the sensory side but you
don't have the motor
side you can have
fasciculations and
these are these isolated
twitches of the muscles
which are not sufficient
really to move the
limb but are just
kind of little quiverings
of the muscle and
then eventually over
time because the muscle
is unused you use it
or lose it it gets lost
so you have atrophy
and the individual that
we see in this picture
I mean he's a fit
guy this is a military
guy but he is has one
thing that is not
developed and that is his
deltoid and that was
because of a lesion to
his axillary nerve
so he was able to get
along in life well but
for certain directions
of motion and he'd be
have to put a little
bit more in there from
other parts of his body
now we're going to be
treating the corticolabar
tract which is the
other half of the
pyramidal system these
are the neurons that
will be destined to
portions of the brainstem
that are going to be
controlling various
cranial nerve nuclei
for the face and so the
cortical bulbar tract
are upper motor neurons
and the cranial nerve
nuclei are the lower
motor neurons because
those are the ones
that will have a axon
that will exit the cns
become a nerve in the
pns and innervate muscle
so the cortical bulbar
tract is that portion
of the pyramidal
system that will be
controlling the
effectors of the head and
that is going to be
allowing cortical control
of chewing of the
upper face lower face
speaking swallowing
tongue movements head
turn and shrug so a
whole pile of functions
that are going to be
the result of activation
of lower motor
neurons within the
brainstem those cranial
nerve nuclei they get
input from upper
motor neurons the
corticobulbar tract now
a notable feature of this
system is that the
there are axons that
will be innervating
cranial nerve nuclei on
both sides will be
ones that will be
decussating and controlling
the contralateral
cranial nerve
nuclei and others
that will stay
on the same
side and control
the ipsilateral
cranial nerve nuclei
and that is the
case for most of
these cranial nerve
nuclei with the
exception here outlined
in red very
important that the
cranial nerve nuclei
for the lower face
only receives input
from the contralateral
hemisphere and what
that means is that
there is no ability
of the system to
compensate if there
is damage on that side
of the cerebral cortex
whereas for the other
functions there will
be compensation.
Now the tongue is
notably asymmetric in its
control. It's primarily
contralateral control
but there is some
ipsilateral control so
this comes up in the
textbooks will come up
in the clinical literature
that you can see
deviations of the
tongue due to a cortical
****** on just one side
and it may not be as
striking as what you'd
have for the lower face
the lower face is very
striking the tongue
may or may not be but
for the others you're
really not going to
see anything because
it's bilateral implant
let's look a little
further on this example
of inability to compensate
for lesioning of the
cortical tract in
terms of the control of
the lower half of the
face we're looking at
this fella and asking
could you please smile
for me and he's not
doing a very good job
of it on the lower
half we can see that lip
turned down while the
forehead is in fact
wrinkling so there's
control of the upper half
on both sides but not
the lower half of the
face on both sides
and this deficit in
function is because the
cranial nerve nuclei that
will be sending axons
to the that ipsilateral
musculature for
the lower half of the
face only receives input
from the contralateral
pyramidal tract from
it was a facial motor
cortex because of the
pyramidal system the
cortical bulbar system
there was a sectioning
and that's why it's
dot dot dot dot because
there's no more input
from that side of
cerebral cortex to the
nucleus for the upper
half and lower half
in the face but the
upper half of the
face also gets input
from the ipsilateral
side hence there
can be compensation
And here we have a
real-life individual
who is expressing
the signs of a
lesion to the
cortical bulbar system
on one side of the
cerebral cortex.
The person's asked to
grin or actually hear
a growl, and we can see
him growling away on
one side with the
upper and lower half of
the face as well as
the upper on the other
side but the lower half
of the face that would
be on his left side
remains flaccid that
means that the damage
is to the contralateral
cerebral cortex so
damage to lower motor
neurons are going to
lead to placidity because
there's just no way of
activating the muscle
from that nerve you've
sectioned it so it's
not going to be able to
release acetylcholine
onto the muscle and
cause contraction
and so you get flaccidity
this would be the
case if you had releasing
of lower motor neurons
for the cortical
spinal system and also
for the um critical
ball bar system this is
an example for the
cortical bulbar system
because of the control of
the face this individual
was struck with bell's
palsy so this is
going to be an irritation
of cranial nerve
seven and amongst the
various fibers that
are carried by that
nerve are the axons to
control the upper and
lower half of the face
and we can see that
one half of his face is
flaccid this individual
is asked to smile did
on one side not on
the other and so he's
gonna have a variety
of other issues because
it's a mixed nerve as I
as I mentioned you can
see listed here a variety
of functions which
will cover a succeeding
lecture but for
the motor side the
important thing is that
one half of his face is
flaccid okay as opposed
to with cortical
bulbar damage you would
have the lower half
of the face would be
flaccid and we have
another example of a lesion
of a cranial nerve or
nuclei this would be
for controlling the
tongue the individual
that we see on the left
when they're asked to
push their tongue
forward stick it out the
tongue will deviate
quite radically to the
side. We see it's
deviating to that person's
left and that would
be the side that they
would have issues
controlling the musculature
because the muscles
on that side could not
oppose those on the
right. So it's the left
musculature that is
flaccid, hence there's a
deviation towards the
left given the type of
mechanical connections
that one finds in the
tongue this can have a
very similar appearance
if you have a a
****** that knocks out
um a restricted region
of the cortical ball
bar system on one side
so this individual
here is also sticking
their tongue out we see
a deviation and it's
not because of a problem
of the nerve or the
nucleus this problem
in the cerebral cortex
we can see this arrow
pointing out this
white area which was a
knocked out portion of
their cortical ball bar
system and this was a
notable paper because
it was very very
localized effect normally
you would be starting
to look for other areas
that might be affected
that would be nearby
and what is nearby
well the hand the hand
would be nearby so you
might see if there's
an effect in the hand
and the tongue you
would be like oh i really
think this is going
to be a problem uh
centrally we you're probably
gonna do an mri
anyway but that's what
you're going down
thinking is most likely um
if you did not see
that you really really
would have to focus
quite well and you might
get a case report because
it's that isolated
lesion just for
the the tongue that
can happen but
that is quite rare
you've been introduced
Broca's area in
several lectures at this
point such a distinctive
region because it
is involved in the
control of speech and
so damage to this area
which is going to be
found in the inferior
frontal gyrus they
call this the percolum
and triangularis if
you really want to nail
on it but inferior
frontal gyrus we have will
result in expressive
aphasia and I have
a link of an individual
suffering from that
and you'll see that
their speech is halting
and it takes a great
deal of effort to
express themselves they
do it in a with very
short snippets they
don't have a fluidity of
speech and so on it
needs to be emphasized
that these people
can eat fine They can
eat. They can drink.
They can open their
mouth. They can smile.
So they do have control
of their articulatory
system for other
actions, but not in the
context of speech. And
now I want you to
understand why the placement
of Broca's areas
makes sense given the
other information
that you have. We have
the face representation
right behind it.
Remember, that's where
the cortical ball bar
system is going to be.
So this is anterior
to that. And what is
anterior as we're moving
on forward? More and
more abstraction in
terms of the motor
command. So it is a frontal
lobe function, it is
a function of doing
things, and for the
face that is more
abstract than chewing,
swallowing, and so on.
you might have noticed
on an earlier slide
that the cortical ball
bar system all the
things that can control
about the face did
not include the eyes the
eyes are not controlled
by the cortical ball
bar system they're
not controlled by the
pyramidal system but
we do have voluntary
control of the eyes
obviously i'd say please
look to the left you
can do it please look
to the right you can
do it so that means
that there are cell
bodies within cerebral
cortex they're making
sending their axons
down to the brain some
cranial nerve nuclei
and what is that where
are those cell bodies
originating within
the cerebral cortex
answer frontal eye fields
those frontal eye fields
are found interior
to area six which
is also known as the
premotor cortex so
interior to premotor
cortex we have the frontal
eye fields area eight
and that is going
to be found on the
superior and middle
frontal gyrus and their
axons will go to some
portion of reticular
formation that's called
peripontine reticular
formation, and from
there to superior
colliculus to control
the eyes. Actually, from
there, from superior
colliculus, then to
the cranial nerve nucleus.
It's a very indirect
relationship because
there's a lot of
complexity that's
involved. Now, how do they
control the eyes?
Let's think about this.
We know that the
cerebral cortex controls
the contralateral
body. right and we know
that this is seen for
other aspects of cerebral
cortex is involved
in the contralateral
world like vision so
like the right occipital
cortex is going to be
involved in processing
information for the
left visual world
and the right motor
cortex is going to be
involved in controlling
effectors of the left
side of the body what
about the eyes well
shouldn't you move
your eyes to that part
of the visual world that
the occipital cortex
on that side cares
about yeah so that
means that the will
move the eyes into the
contralateral visual
field so that the right
frontal eye fields
will move the eyes to
the left okay direct
the gaze to the left if
you have a problem
with the frontal eye
fields because of a
****** you will have
deviation of the eyes
in a way that would be
consistent with that
imbalance so we tonically
deviated to the same
side you can't move
to the side that you
normally would had there
not been this deficit
and so you could
also miss out you can
have some a bit of a
neglect of that world
simply because you're
not moving your eyes
to that now would the
person be fine on a
test of VOR function,
which we know depends
entirely on brainstem
nuclei, that is, you
passively move the head,
twist it left and
right, ask them to gaze
straight ahead. Yeah,
they would be fine
on that. But this
intentional control to
direct their eyes, they
would be compromised.
The brainstem nuclei
for controlling the body
include tickler nucleus
reticular formation
and vestibular nucleus
these are focused
on controlling the
proximal muscles of the
limbs and the axis so
their uh representation
in a uh as a homunculus
would be like we
have on the left with
really bulked out uh
shoulders and pecs
and quads and abs very
different than what we
have with a homunculus in
the cerebral cortex
where that would be
these very large hands
and a very large face.
Now I mentioned the
red nucleus, which is
going to be the origin
for the rubrospinal
tract from the red
to the spine because
it's brought up in
so many different
textbooks. and it is
a prominent tract in
monkey models which
are commonly used to
understand motor control
but for humans that
rubrospinal tract is
actually very small.
Now we have a massive
red nucleus and that
is doing things that
are very important for
motor control and how
it communicates with
the cerebellum but the
part of red nucleus
that projects to the
spinal cord is in fact
very small in humans
and it did have affected
before the contralateral
upper limbs I
mentioned this as a almost
as a cautionary note
when you read these
other textbooks because
they will be referring
to animal models
because they're doing so
many studies on animal
models and sometimes
you cannot generalize
across different
animals and this really
exemplifies that there
are nuclei within the
brain stem that are
part of reticular
formation which is you
might remember is very
complex structure
comprising many different
nuclei and the ones that
are within the brain
stem that project to
the spinal cord are
called reticulospinal
and there's ones that
are situated in the
pons and medulla and
there's going to be
lateral tracts and medial
tracts I'm not holding
you to that suffice to
say that there are a
number of tracks within
the brainstem that
are part of reticular
formation that descend
to control the body.
For the most part,
these have bilateral
projections. It's a very
large system and it's
quite understudied
because it's very
technically difficult to
record from these neurons
because you're deep
within the brainstem.
Despite being understudied,
we do have some
important knowledge about
what are capabilities
within the reticular
formation for
controlling the body.
There's this structure
called MLR, the mesencephalic
locomotor region,
that when you stimulate
it in a cat, the
cat has been sectioned
so it has no input
from the cerebral
cortex. You can have this
cat standing on a
treadmill, stimulate this
MLR of the brainstem,
part of the reticular
formation, projections
necessarily going to
the reticular spinal
tract, and you'll get
coordinated walking. The
reason I'm mentioning
this is because
this is an important
site therapeutically
that people are now
targeting with deep brain
stimulation and was 60
years after it was
originally discovered.
We also have the
asymmetrical tonic reflex,
which is something
that is seen within
children, newborns, that
if their head is turned
to the side, then
that arm will flex and
the other arm, which
the head is turning away
from, will involuntarily
flex. And this
will be re-expressed
with cortical ******.
You remember with
cortical ******, you have
that automatic flexion.
Well, some of the
circuitry for that is
shown within newborns,
this reemergence of
reflex patterns that were
dormant. And lastly,
I should mention
startle. So you walk
behind somebody, you know,
on a dark and rainy
night in the parking
lot and give a little
shout behind them. They
give a little startle
and flex their arms
together. That flexing
protective response
is another example of
a system controlled
through reticulospinal
tract, but getting its
original information
from the, obviously,
from the vestibular system.
so the communication
from other systems
to reticulospinal
tract not just um
somatosensory information
vestibular spinal
tract is quite powerful
in humans and is engaged
if you were to fall
to the left or fall
to the right it would
be responsible for
extending your legs on the
side that you're
falling towards and we
know that's the
vestibulospinal tracts because
of those connection
patterns but also the
what happens when you
sever all the other
nuclei that could be
projecting from the
cerebral cortex from
the brainstem aside from
the vestibular nucleus
so there's a section
just above the upper
medulla when that's
done to a kitty cat
then we see extension of
all of its limbs and so
this has anti-gravity
function for the upper
limbs and for the
lower limbs and this
is most certainly the
responsibility of the
vestibulospinal tract
so those brainstem
tracks that we talked
about can be manifest
under situations of
severe brain damage so
these are individuals
that would be
unconscious and you could
have somebody come
into the er and if they
show this posture
where the legs are
extended um and their
upper extremities that's
you the upper
extremities are flexed as
a mummy pose they call
that decorticate and
this is associated
with a lesion above
the red nucleus so you'll
still have continued
um activity of the
regions there below
the red nucleus so that
would include itself
red nucleus reticular
formation and
vestibular nucleus and
so this means that the
red nucleus is
projecting to us is that
it's going to be
actually connected to the
cerebellum that's
what's going to still
have that connection
going on but regardless
it's the hyperactivity
of the remaining
nuclei that are involved
and We know that
this elbow flexion
is something that's
very prominent for
the reticular system.
If the individual
shows a decerebrate
posture, that is
that their legs are
extended and their
upper extremities
are extended, this
is a worse situation
than before. Here,
this indicates that
the lesion is below
the red nucleus.
So red nucleus is no
longer involved. Now
you have the hyperactivity
of reticulospinal
and the vestibular
nuclei. And it's
interesting that this
is an extension of both
because you still have
reticulospinal. So
there's complexities
that we do not yet
understand, but we know
that most certainly
the red nucleus in its
modulatory role vis
-a-vis the cerebellum
is in suffice to say
if you're showing a
decerebrate posture
meaning that the lower
extremity and the
upper extremities are
both extended then that
means that the
damage is more severe
because it's extending
below the red nucleus
locked in syndrome is
when you have a lesion
within the pons that
is so dense that
it will interrupt the
flow of information
from cerebral cortex
down to any levels
within the pons and
below so it's going to
knock out all control
for voluntary control
of the body it's going
to knock out so much
voluntary control of
the of the head of
the face of the neck
of chewing and so on
what is left is blinking
and a little bit
of eye movements
because those are the
responsibility of
cranial nerve nuclei that
are above the lesion
that are in the midbrain
ocular motor nucleus
trochlear nucleus.
Those people can
blink, but they can't
say anything. You would
normally think these
folks are in a vegetative
state, that they
do not have consciousness,
but they do.
They're locked in
their body. They can't
tell you what they're
experiencing. They
can still feel the
world, but they can't do
anything about it.
These cases have
invariably been missed
when they interview people
afterwards. The
time by which people
finally realized it
may have been months
later, may have been
years later. Very, very
difficult to imagine
what that was like.
There is efforts underway
to try to address
this with different
devices that are going
to be detecting where
people can look on a
screen and communicate
that way allow faster
interactions it was a
beautiful book and a
movie i encourage you
to watch called the
divide diving bell and
the butterfly it was
written by this guy
because he blinked it
out he blinked out this
book it's not a terribly
long book as soon
as it went to press
uh the fella uh passed
on but he had a contract
to write a book and
he said i'm going to
enforce it they they've
made one with me
i'm going to write it.
And it's a fantastic
book by a very cultured
editor of a fashion
journal in France. It's
a little while ago.
All right, let's wrap up.
Both the corticospinal
tract and the
corticobulbar tract are
going to arise from
precentral gyrus as
well as rostral adjacent
cortex. The corticospinal
tract is going
to project to the
contralateral spinal
cord, whereas
the corticobulbar
tract is going to
project bilaterally
to cranial nerve
nuclei, except for the
facial nucleus, which is
going to be exclusively
contralateral for
the lower half of the
face. Upper motor
neuron damage can be
expressed as weakness
and ******* paralysis.
Lower motor
neuron damage is
expressed as
flaccid paralysis.
Different descending
projections from the
brainstem have different
projection patterns.
And damage above
and below the red
nucleus leads to
decorticate and decerebrate
rigidity respectively i
hope that presentation
was clear i understand
some complex
material. Feedback is
always appreciated.